since that day that you had to talk with
your parents and you decided to take
that you know course change from being a
dentist to now acting have you ever
thought back about it no never never
it's never crossed your mind you know
there were a couple times I romero's
waiting tables it was okay it was in the
middle of a double and I had people like
throwing things at me
he's just it could sometimes waiting
tables can be a terrible miserable job
and even then I was like should I should
I just stop right now stop what I'm
doing go back and then and I was
thinking about dental school how much
that kind of terrible I was like now I
could do what people throwing tacos at
me you know I'll throw them back it's
just like I use that energy sometimes
when it gets really bad and I almost
throw it right back at people where I
put into an audition or I put into a you
know you know character that I'm working
on and that I kind of you know eases the
pain sometimes when you're going through
rough times and there are there
absolutely ebbs and flows in a career
you know sometimes you're you're working
every single day for five six months
sometimes you can't get an audition it's
it's crazy so since you have that
athlete's mentality
do you have an ability to say okay I'm
now taking off my apron or my nametag or
whatever that Michael is done that's
just a role I play and now I'm going
back to my real life and then what do
you do to get yourself back on track
because I've had those jobs to work
you're just so down about what just
happened you have to do things that make
you happy when it's not in terms of
acting you have to go for me play soccer
if you like running I hate running but
some people like to run run run run run
you don't have no addition that week run
go do things to distract yourself that
make you happy but also better yourself
running athletics these are all good
things they keep you in shape right if
you like the party party but that's
where you can get into trouble because
people get caught up in that and then
they're not actors anymore they're just
people who pretend to be actors who are
just partying all day and trying to
network do you see that a lot I don't go
out anymore
I am completely focused on what's going
on in LA since I moved here I don't
really go out I go out it's you know
with with friends or people I like to
hang out with like a close circle and
I really drink because it's that's
something that doesn't really help me
anymore I did enough drinking in New
York you know I party a lot in New York
so it's here it's in LA for me it's work
and being an artist and just bettering
yourself as an actor do you remember the
day that you had that decision because
that's an amazing epiphany especially
being young handsome I'm sure there's
all these opportunities you get a lot of
attention when you go out but then there
is a flip side and then years can be
wasted when I got here I realized what I
was up against I got here what about a
year ago and I saw how many actors were
here in New York I knew there were a lot
of actors you know and you're competing
with all those actors but here you're
competing with probably 10 times the
amount of actors so what's your edge
right you have to ask yourself how am I
better than these people what's gonna
make me stand out you have to look
better you have to be a better actor you
have to be everything and what is
drinking really good - for me that
completely goes against everything that
I was doing so I was starting out of the
gym I started to research more classes I
started to surround myself with artists
I joined a theater company and that's
how it actually did that play trust
which got some pretty good reviews in LA
Weekly recently so that that was a
success because it was like I didn't
have any auditions going on go take go
join a theater company and good things
came out of that so it's just constantly
finding ways to better your career and
going out and partying it doesn't really
do much for me anymore
you